[Music]
on the road again in our series of more
perfect union aims to show us what
unites us as americans is more far more
greater than what divides us this
morning we share a story of a father and
his young daughter who teamed up to
provide temporary shelter for those who
have lost everything jamie wax shows a
daughter and a father who are helping
rebuild communities and connecting with
each other jamie good morning good
morning nate that's right the duo from
denver is driving rvs hundreds of miles
and donating donating them to people who
lost homes in the california wildfires
along their journey they're learning and
teaching valuable lessons about giving
should we get a snack are you doing okay
yeah
what are you thinking i don't know
some healthy vegetarian gas station
options
woody faircloth and his nine-year-old
daughter luna are getting used to life
on the road
for the last three years they've been
taking special trips to deliver rvs to
families who've lost homes in wildfires
it's a mission they began after watching
news of the deadly 2018 camp fire in
california i turned to luna who was six
at the time she had no front teeth
and i said luna
you know why don't we get an rv and
we'll drive it to california and give it
to a family so they have a place to call
home for thanksgiving luna you said
something very special right then at
that thanksgiving yeah i said
dad god and santa claus are going to be
very proud of us
and do you feel
like god and santa claus are very proud
of you yes
fair cloth began looking for rv donors
and was amazed by how many people wanted
to help with unwanted rvs or their time
we have volunteers all over the country
that have helped us we have people right
now that are answering emails and
processing paperwork for for these
donations i mean it's
just raise your hand and say hey i'd
like to help they can come home and make
a home-cooked meal and dad and daughter
have personally delivered about 20 rvs
to folks in need mostly firefighters
first responders and veterans and he's
helped arrange around a hundred
donations in all but it's also been an
opportunity to teach his daughter
oh look at the palm trees everywhere
along their trips are reminders of the
cost of these fires look at the ground
how is this ash and they've developed a
stronger bond it's been really special
for the two of us just to be able to
spend that time together and to make a
difference just so she knows that it's
not just about her and it's not just
about me it's about the people that
we're helping and
you know we've we're blessed oh my gosh
it's so
like
bumpy
we joined them on a trip from denver to
reading california all right now we're
stretch
they were there to deliver a new home
that's beautiful to don george a
firefighter who lost nearly everything
when his own home burned in the fawn
fire this past september while he was
helping to save others homes
i went to the crew and i go hey i got i
got to go check on my house and it was
already too late my son says i don't
know how to tell you
but
he just couldn't even talk he just he
didn't know how to say it
nope it's gone
george has been fighting fires for
nearly 50 years he's used to being the
one doing the rescuing is that your
co-pilot
his role changed when the fair cloths
arrived i got keys for you
thank you i got a title for you when we
visited george a few weeks later look at
the crown molding and everything i mean
it's just absolutely gorgeous he'd
received a second donated rv so that his
adult sons who lived with their parents
could also have a place to live all i
can say is thank god for woody you
couldn't ask for a better man he came
just exactly the right time for me
renewed my faith in mankind man if there
was more people like that we'd have a
beautiful world
all these families we feel like are
they're part of our family now and we
stay in touch and we we hear their
stories and share their successes you
continue to be a community absolutely
and the experience has also helped a
little girl grow wise beyond her years
what makes you most proud um
that i've made a really big change in
the world
for a lot of people
do you want people to see this
and decide children and adults that they
can do the same thing yes
what can we all do to help make that
happen
just
be nicer to each other
ah yes yes how much better place would
the world be if we were more like luna
yes yes luna well done setting a great
example for his daughter she's right god
and santa are proud i think so yeah
we'll be right back